[Music]
well what's in the box on Beavis I'm but
hey guess what we're gonna get all up in
this box that's not a dirtier than I
meant - Jason's got a knife here we go
most dangerous parts show watch oh yeah
here we go kids
living up to the moniker right what's
your name
I see Oh Tiberius
Star Trek Tiberius Buddha Twala was the
toilet water which is in another
language perfume Oh
along it's not toilet mortar but that's
right now food--it wallah toilet water
oh it's a black widow I think it's a
lubricant no he's gotta be for external
use so it's definitely not a lubricant
harmful if swallowed Russians but well
let's get them all out see what's behind
oh oh there's the bat what is this
Batman who dis wallet toilet water bat
walk Oh Superman as well I think we
found the theme kids gone far dude this
is eau de pon Fahr that's when I've been
a Vulcan goes through puberty this is
the smell of puberty right here
yeah not PR Rhonda there's a James Bond
clone who knew that redshirt Cologne
they've even got Cologne for the red
shirts Jade smell Bob Cologne
all right minutes we got this vine array
of genre clone and perfume which as a
longtime fan genre enthusiast I find
this insulting because essentially
they're going to y'all stink y'all smell
and they're here's here's what you'll
wear because it's got your superheroes
on them and they read me right cuz I
would totally buy it Batman Cologne what
are you wearing
like jakar something [ __ ] all right so
now you know how this dude does right I
just I'm gonna sprite and then you walk
into my house how it happens ready go
walk into it what does it feel like
I don't do anything I don't think enough
came out yeah alright here we go ready
yeah walk it nice the bat would do a
punch through it man good point
kids Lauren what does it smell like
feels smells oh that smells like justice
right there that is what justice smells
like it doesn't smell like that man at
all no I just felt like my mother
we're not even my mother my grandmother
this smells like old age and somebody
praying for Jesus to take her at age 82
it's not Batman at all smells like if
anything it smells like the Batcave
toilet really it smells like a urinal
cake yeah yes yeah Batman fails sorry
yes well let's try in the world of
Batman V Superman here's the real fight
which one smells better okay ready
test up you start there I'll put it
there here we go and you will believe a
man can fly go nice was it smell like
smells like the daily planets [ __ ] I
got to tell you it doesn't smell like
that man I thought for a second that
they would both smell the same no it's
like who would want to smell like that
night it would make people be like did
you come out of the bathroom will you
glory holy that's what it smells like it
smells like a glory hole I don't know
what that smells like I'm 6 I guess
let's jump into James Bond dude you'd
imagine ladies yes smooth man good look
at this it looks like a weapon the
bottles are nice likely that I mean
grads and of course all you could do is
put us in LA but maybe shape it like
something yeah this looks like a little
flask let's see how this moves oh and oh
look at this oh surprise James Mike you
would be like you here basically you do
this and then you put it on license to
thrill go
nice very nice what's it smell like Oh
smells like you small this kind of
smells like Superman same from the same
thing literally almost the same thing I
feel like I'm at Nordstrom's yeah
alright so right now I'm gonna put
Batman in the lead
sentimental nostalgia style I'm gonna
put this you know what bond first
because the bottle is cool alright let's
be honest the fragrances so far they all
smell kind of the same but this this is
the magic Star Wars Celebration 5
exclusive limited edition ooh
Oh Lando cologne for men CardPlayer
gambler scoundrel you like Han Solo what
have we here come on it comes with you
know it comes with the land oh yes it's
a wiener King now you truly you belong
with us here in the clouds exactly all
your finest bottles of perfume back up
put a sticker right on the bottle look
at that name tribe they were like we
tried with the Cape the rest is just
gonna be sticker wear this I would wear
this Cape I wouldn't wear this one let's
see what it smells like here you go
ready huh alright looking for love with
Lobot go smooth like colt 45 that says
that smells like rubbing alcohol it's
horrible yeah the smells like witch
hazel it smells like your grandmother's
like rub this on my back that's Lando
not at all they're not winning for scent
let's be honest none of these are gonna
win for scent but this is winning for
packaging right there all right let's
see
Pawn far this is the smell of Vulcan
puberty if I remember correctly here's
Bernie this all right box it's got this
very nice perfume
I don't know if it's for men or women
here we go ready and live long and
prosper yeah cuz you know I bet it's
perfume bro it smells like candy yeah
yeah bubble gum all right you actually
percent so far palms pon Fahr is the
leader let's say this is our good pile
for what smells good and this is our
cool-looking pile yeah this is Black
Widow man the Black Widow perfume for
assassins pollicis sons rear um Spacey's
I can't speak that language
maybe it's Russia alright here we go
what's really bad too is you're like
punch punch to us and then you did a big
inhale I watched it all go into your
lungs that also smells medicine and yes
smell like it doesn't make you wanna
LaHaye you smell good and makes you go
like oh are you dying
but that's like the worst brows so far
I'm telling you um let's go for all
right Meyer man mark for cologne man
come on Tony Stark he's got a good right
there's no way that dude don't smell
like sex and joy
let's see man you go OD Robert Downey
jr. and repulsor ray nice but again
smells like booze that would make sense
demon in the bottle yes I sorry - when
you're at the bar and [ __ ] there's
alcohol all over this actually it smells
and tastes like seven ovens which is a
mixer that's the best like 7up doesn't
it don't you add about seven right there
maybe the secret of sprite I'm thinking
booze it's lime I gotta tell you this
actually smells good and put it right
next to the pond far let's try another
hero asked me on the Hulk smash dude we
got a smell what Hawk smiles legs
alright but first I want you to tell the
audience what is this Hulk smash what is
it Hulk there's Mary
the first time Hawk smash Hawk Hawk is a
bird Hulk
all right Hulk smash dude oh we need a
knife for that yeah
remember kids always keep your knife
handy look how lame dude there's their
logo because he doesn't have his own
like a chime shirt or something just
says smash be angry it looks like the
bottle supposed to be cracked oh my god
yeah right now for design so far the
Hulk is in last place but he could still
win in the cent division here we go and
what are you getting listen I don't know
it's weird okay I got to tell you got to
do four pumps that smelled like vodka I
think they're like look nobody's ever
gonna open these let's just put booze in
them yeah that's that's that's going in
a new football and the bottle design the
absolute yeah yeah I know somebody works
hard on that we're carded they told me
after tusks all right here you go
Patriot Oh very or attack plan for
Captain America okay let's see if this
smells like Chris Evans at all throw
your mighty shield that's most flowery
of us almost like uh and this smells
like fresh he's spread in your bathroom
after you drop it dude yes smells like
renews it more than anything else
probably there yeah for worthy Cologne
and I can lift it so apparently I
haven't done that yeah to flourish with
the knife just so we can open up for
work alone when my father saw his baby
son come out of his wife for the first
time he never thought he'd spend his
adulthood and smelling colognes and
superheroes on the mist of possess the
power men right it's gonna smell like
lightning bro this guys smell like Norse
mythology ready
[Music]
oh it smells like [ __ ]
really yeah absolutely smell like it
really smells like like that is bad yeah
that's tan yeah it's got like a not turn
ass baby
we're a little patchouli even yeah my
ass Thor why would Thor have patchouli
on him I'm not into that
let me see Tiberius don't watch so this
is named for James Tiberius Kirk so this
one's gonna be smooth man Hey ladies
Kirk oh look at even the bottle proud of
her design still I feel like the Lando
bottles nice but this now blows check
all our nice design got a little logo
Pete and look even the capless quasi
futuristic okay I had no idea there was
a market for genre colognes man I really
feel like we're missing a JSON Bob
cologne could smell like weed and Kirk
it up
smells like Captain Kirk's chair after
us we're so ready dad not very good and
put that in the last one cows all right
this has a little bit of bottle man so
far upon far and then who is the other
surprise the Iron Man really nice a
dabble oh oh
this may get it for design that's pretty
sweet but like they want the distance
putting a cake yeah I would have loved
to been in the marketing meeting like
how do we make land ocala a cologne to
like you know okay this is a red shirt
ready go get killed oh it's not that's
horrible - it's very bad yeah I
understand why anyone thinks that in
space they'd wear patchouli they're like
that's far we left Earth we hate that
smell but I do like the red design of
the box yes best smells best bottles
just rot or crap more like keep it in
the box
ah let's see we got two choices here for
best bottle and packaging hands-down it
goes to Orlando
oh I gotta disagree I'm thinking
double-oh-seven because as the cool like
hip-hip Dugan so you say what you like
is just like wow yeah but you like the
subterfuge you like the idea that people
who see you holding that
for all they know you're just holding
the bottle but when they turn around you
twist it spray it and not to mention the
bottle itself think about it not very
good you could put a cape on this song
that's not fair you can't take the kid
from once what about others that you can
what they didn't think to do the Cape
and water James Bond I mean it you
wouldn't need it believe it only I give
it to Lando you give us Jim James Barton
and Landon we got a split decision to
your kids by two guys that never wear
Cologne now let's go to this side man
that was just for design and alright
smell okay okay alright now here we go I
gotta give it to pon Fahr that one yeah
me too I think so let's take a cool 7up
B whatever but now wouldn't wear that
and it's too but that I'd wear so I
agree with that one as well this is it
right here if you're going out on a hot
date man or woman don't matter you dab a
little pond far behind the ears man
you're gonna be like you're gonna live
long and prosper
what is uh what is this stuff cost man
I'm gonna stay
Oh Lando go for about $29.99 am i right
39.95
ten bucks you pay the premium for the
cake that's worth it yeah what would you
think with this little little double oh
look at Luke's what would I think I
would think what an incredible waste of
time and money this all is but if I as
you then asked me what I would think of
a cost I would say 25 88 2474 my friend
2474 yeah I made up 88 go on like that's
ridiculous but their price point is 74
cents somebody in an office was like
let's go $25.99 I like don't do that
nobody's gonna buy 2474 we got some
sales oh wait a second I'm not very good
at this
reading sorry I could read but I'm
saying that I did then says in the
current James Bond novels he wears
Flores number 89 Cologne that's an
actual fragrance you can still buy made
what is it terrain street fragrance I
want to put on some of these fragrances
on them so they're saying that fragrance
just retails for about $80 a bottle so
sorry not this bottle not this the
mister this 2474 top notes Apple
cardamom sandalwood vita ver all those
ingredients yes yeah there wasn't enough
lavender I'm a big lavender fan if they
put if they could have made one of these
all lavender and that would have been
light and I should have done it for the
Lando one because the Cape is kind of a
parish maybe not but I would have put
more lavender in it but I'm not a scent
maker so what I do make sense but nobody
wants to smell those mandarin intense
lotus flower mannequin oranges are
violet sensuous Musk Oh centers musk
there has much to I that's what I
smelled in a lot of this craft like
throwing some more Musk
look at that red shirt bottle man most
interesting man in the world Jonathan
Goldsmith plate of red shirt know that
guy he's the most interesting man in the
world from those commercials yeah yeah
he played a red shirt on the second ever
Star Trek episode which is what do you
do you know what it's called no I do not
neither no how's gonna pretend like I
did
Corbin I Corbin might maneuver some
people watching this like corporal I see
fat ass all sorry Corbin mind um he
lives to the episode he's one of the
only red shirts that doesn't die that's
what makes him one of the most
interesting mental items our favorite
scent in here yeah let's do this
like it's not throw around our favorites
but one that didn't make us vomit this
yes that one we chose was best of the
best
it's the no hora and Spock themed
perfume with floral fruity highlights
pon Fahr every seven years like they go
through heat Vulcans like they're always
logical stuff but every seven years he's
like I've got wood that won't quit
captain and so he has to have sex every
seven years of Vulcan doesn't have sex
they go crazy - every seventy every
seven days seven days I know it's true
many Vulcans only have sex during pon
farr but it's possible to have Vulcan
sex at any time yeah so don't just wait
for pon farr kids sex is good for any
time of day oh man I cannot smell a
thing I think I've burned out all the
sensory nerves endings in my nose
because we've smelled such cheap
horrible perfume man but had a good time
doing it you want to see us open up
other things yes tell us tell us what
you want to see us open somebody
literally wrote open up colognes and we
did it not weird you can ask for
something we'll do it man right to the
screen junkies like their twitter
account go to their Facebook page or
write write them an email somewhere on
this screen you can click on it and get
right to them and stuff tell us what you
want to see us open up or what you want
us to say we'll say things just put
things in our mouths yes what we're here
for
until next week I'm Kevin Smith Jason
Mewes see you next time on what's in the
box what's in the box it's crap what's
in this box horrible things I don't want
to put up your nose
you